a bizarre incident caught on police body
camera video showing an Indiana woman
threatening to cut off the heads of
officers before she claims to be part of
Isis what is that
oh that's okay
yeah that's where I am I indeed on June
11th officials in Evansville Indiana
responded to a spectrum Communications
store for reports of arson once they
arrived police officers found
43-year-old Sierra Malloy who admitted
she was responsible
[Music]
Mali told officers she took down the
businesses American flag set it on fire
and replaced it with an Isis flag body
camera video shows an officer respond to
the scene where Malawi is already cuffed
she can be heard saying she owns the
officers
thank you
don't forget
I own you don't forget I own you don't
forget okay
let me take our personal property down
yes yes
thank you
[Music]
yeah my parents are the worst time God
yeah he ain't with your
[Laughter]
look I'm telling you right now you
better get your hands off a seat
thank you
less than a minute after the recording
begins Malloy threatens the officers
with decapitation yeah y'all gonna get
fired because I feel good your head's
off
my head yeah
who I am dude
she goes on to wish the officers a happy
911.
yeah you're gonna find out who I am you
Hunter bin Laden
huh you don't tell me nothing about
Finland you don't even know who you
serve you're God's bad I was asking if
that's who you are you sure
yeah I might be how do you know maybe
you've been alive maybe I am 9 11. happy
9 11. oh Saddam Hussein yeah you've been
hit by Terry
you know I said I'm Hussein was hiding
in a hoe because y'all were trying to
hide in the hotel Maui also tells the
officers they've been hit by terrorists
and alleges they have children hidden
under government buildings
[Laughter]
we kind of did
well you know what he's going
yeah yeah you've been hit by Tears for
the worst time you just don't
know it yet
indeed watch what I tell you boys
indeed
you sir bow you got children on these
government buildings confusing them
drinking their blood
if you don't tell me
officials then try to ask Maloy if she's
under the influence of any drugs but she
refuses to answer
let me ask you one question you don't
ask me nothing what kind of drugs I
ain't no no drugs
[Laughter]
you sell my children to pedophiles
yeah you gotta
uh that are you all right hey I'm just
fine all right
yeah you all right I'll Think You Are
well I guess you start the wagon
um probably so definitely not
transported
too bad for you
at this point in the recording an
officer notices the flag what is that
it is an Islamic right
now
yeah that's right
[Music]
Mallory was taken into custody and now
faces multiple charges including
Criminal Trespass criminal mischief and
flag desecration reporting for long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie